sir sir sir
Pack 1 jump the gun the gun to kill them
hey if we can have one of the art PD
units walk down to me over here to get
enough Rodgers please we need okay you
guys got we need fire to be able to get
down here move the cars all PD we need
to move the cars we need to get fire
down here we need fire near mass move
the vehicles yes Raleigh they come to
RPGs got the crowd handle but EMS needs
to come down to the dead end
Rogers for more they can come down
duckling away if they come down duckling
away he'll see a patrol vehicle they can
stop at that patrol vehicle
we got one GSW to the stomach you still
talking to us he just keeps saying he
can't breathe chuckling why I just told
them but you can tell them on your right
he'll be faster we got we go come on
love ya honey
here tourist Xavier 1 GSW
you